والى تبعات الزلزال على سوريا عدد قتل هذا
الزلزال بلغ
5840 شخصا اما عدد مصابين فقد ارتفع الى
اكثر من عشره الاف وخمس مئه الشكاوي
وتزداد من وجود فجوه كبيره بين الاحتياجات
العاجله للمنكوبين وما يقدم لهم من
مساعدات عن هذا الموضوع
معنا صهيب الخلف مراسل الجزيره على معبر
باب الهوى هذا المعبر الذي
ينقل او تنقل عبره المساعدات القادمه الى
شمال السوري اخبرنا اكثر عن هذا الموضوع
وحركه المعبر اليوم صهيب
نعم انتهى دخول المساعدات الامميه اليوم
ودخلت ثلاث وثلاثون شاحنه استقرت في ساحه
معبر باب الهوى قبل ان يتم تسليمها
للمنظمات الشريكه مع الامم المتحده بذلك
وبحسب اداره معبر باب الهوى تكون يكون عدد
الشاحنات التي دخلت الى سوريا
161 شاحنه من تلك الشاحنات التي تحمل
المساعدات الامميه والتي تصل الى
المتضررين والمنكوبين من الزلزال عاده ما
تحمل مستلزمات خيام ومستلزماتها وايضا
تحمل ادويه ومواد غذائيه لكن طبعا وبالنظر
الى عدد المتضررين الكبير بالنسبه للزلزال
وبحسب منظمه منسق واستجابه فان هذه
المساعدات لا تكفي لتلبيه كل احتياجات
اولئك الذين تضرروا من اولئك الذين نزحوا
والذين يبلغوا عددهم اكثر من 100 الف شخص
او الذين يجلسون في مراكز ايواء مؤقته
يتهددها المرض وهم اكثر من 7000 عائله
بحسب المنظمه نفسها
هنا في معبر باب الهوى لو اردنا الانتقال
الى الحركه او الجانب الاخر من حركه هذه
او هذا المعبر يمكن للكاميرا ان تنتقل الى
دخول الحافلات التي تصل من الجانب التركي
والتي تقل اللاجئين السوريين الذين يدخلون
الى
الجانب السوري هنا في هذا المكان في هذه
الصاله تتخذ لهم اجراءات روتينيه
وبذلك يدخلون الى الاراضي السوريه طبعا
الحسن كان من بين الواصلين قبل قليل عائله
زميلنا ادهم ابو الحسام نقول له حمدا على
سلامتهم وان شاء الله يقضوا اجازه هادئه
في سوريا طبعا كانوا قد تعرضوا لاوقات
عصيبه ايضا كما كل كما السوريين والاتراك
في الولايات التركيه التي تضررت بسبب
الزلزال هنا في هذه النقطه اذا يتابع
السوريون اجراءات الدخول الى سوريا
وقبل قليل ايضا ساعدت الى حافله من
الوافدين سالتهم عن المناطق التي جاءوا
منها بعضهم جاء من انطاكيا ومن اضنه وكذلك
من مارش هنا التقينا باحدى السيدات قالت
بانها لم ترى سوريا منذ سبعه منذ سبع
اعوام وحقيقه رغم الماسي الكبيره ورغم كل
ما تعرضت له العائلات
فهناك حاله من الفرح حقيقه عندما يدخلون
الى سوريا لقضاء اجازه مدتها بين ثلاث وست
اشهر شكرا
بالخلف من معبر بادي الهوى